lordstown motors another pre-revenue
ev spec so it's pre-revenue that's one
thing
it's in a really hard space electric
vehicles
and it's a spec a way to get public
quicker maybe
with less scrutiny not in all cases but
you do have to buy or beware when you're
looking at this category of companies
going public they tend to be early
uh they confirmed they're being
investigated by
the doj for its reporting of pre-orders
uh oh like it's one thing to not even
have
customers but then to lie about
pre-orders
this is really gnarly so two weeks ago
the wall street journal reported the doj
was inquiring with lordstown which cnbc
confirmed okay so we got
real journalistic outlets wall street
journal on cnbc confirming that the doj
is looking now
they're inquiring that doesn't mean
they're guilty right just because
somebody's looking into something
doesn't mean
um that there is a crime it just means
there's a suspicion
and there's enough of suspicion that the
doj would take it seriously and they
have a large list
of things they could look into and
they've chosen to look into this one
major red
flag lordstown motors said in a filing
on thursday that it had received two
subpoenas from the sec
for the production of documents and
information including relating to the
merger
between diamond peak and legacy
lordstown and pre-orders of vehicles
and we have been informed by the u.s
attorney's office for the southern
district of new york
that it is investigating this matter and
we hear about the southern district of
new york all the time that's where rudy
giuliani started his career before going
absolutely bonkers that's where preet
bharara from the great
cafe insider go to cafe.com and
subscribe to his amazing podcast or stay
tuned with pre which is a free one
anyway if the southern district of new
york is involved
that is a major red flag they are
serious and they are known for having a
very independent streak to them
um so before we break down lord's town i
want to remember
uh jason's law jason's law is something
i came up with
and i codified it i think in september
of 2020 i've been talking about it for
years but
this is my i called it originally my
theranose rule if a startup becomes
worth one billion before they launch
their product
they are either going to fail or be
complete fraud examples punch up let's
workshop this
and i did in fact uh punch it up in
december 20.
remember jason's law if you invest in a
company without a launch product and
over a bill at
over a billion dollar valuation you will
lose all your money and it might turn
out to be a fraud so i've been
workshopping this concept
nicola uh ticker symbol nkla is a
private company
as a private company i said in this
tweet would be worth about 100 million
dollars max
so i expected in this tweet to lose 95
we had trevor milton on the pod episode
number
1090 it is a classic episode it will be
one of the 10 best episodes of my career
because my god this person was
delusional and i
i think that was like peak trevor and it
all came apart shortly thereafter
so in march 2021 i made my third version
of jason's rule if a private company
reaches a one billion dollar valuation
before it launches a product
or has customers it's probably going to
fail
and it might actually be a fraud so be
careful retail investors when you buy
fisker or nicola you're taking a big
risk and so
the reason i refine this is um it's very
rare for a private company to reach a
billion dollar valuation before it
launches a product
or has customers and i i put that caveat
in there because
you could have people pre-ordering uh
things like virgin
galactic which had a very successful
launch this past weekend congratulations
to richard branson
and when you think about that they did
have i think 600 pre-orders of 200k
those people actually paid money or you
have people pre-ordering cars now
whether it's tesla or ford
so i could see a situation in where
which people pre-order
and give their money those are not
letters of intent so keep that in mind
but it seems like i'm now reminding
people of jason's law
every three to four months so consider
this your three to four month quarterly
reminder
and some very important things to keep
in mind about these red flags that we
just covered
valuations that don't make logical sense
what
would this company's valuation be let's
take a spacking company be in the
private markets well sometimes you know
because there's been a private market
valuation in other words airbnb before
they went public had this private market
valuation now they're going public now
that's a company airbnb that we all have
rented airbnbs or we know somebody so
they have a
product in market and tons of customers
and tons of revenue so they don't fall
under jason's law
but as an example you know the the
previous valuation nicola peaked at
around 34
billion dollars in june of 2020 with no
revenue
and basically close to no product as far
as anybody can tell
and i mentioned that as a private
company ventures investors would have
probably invested at them around 100
million max you put in 20 million you
get 20
of the company that seems you know like
a rich valuation but
you know it's reasonable for a hardware
company like that that's capital
intensive um but but that's a 340
multiple from my valuation and i am an
expert on this this is what i do for a
living for 10 years i've invested in
over 300
early-stage private uh market companies
i know what i'm talking about
and so now they're trading at around 5.5
billion which is about 50 times
uh too high and so once again if you
can't see who's holding the bag
check your hands it's probably you so
the people who bought
nikola at 34 billion thinking oh well
this is a fraction of the valuation of
apple or tesla or
amazon you're literally comparing the
most successful
companies in the history of humanity
against you know some dip bleep
the second half of that word please get
some dip
who's never accomplished anything in
their life be
careful out there and what are the
insiders doing this is another thing you
have to look at
are have they exited or are they cashing
out most of the time
the people who are running the best
companies have inside information
that leads them to not want to sell it
and 100 of the time the people running a
company have inside information like
literally
in their brains are their plans and
their hopes and fears and their
assessment of
is this a good stock to own if those
insiders are cashing out it's a red flag
now
if they're cashing out modestly that can
be reasonable if it's a
person's first company if they have to
pay their taxes because they got awarded
some stock
there are some valid reasons that an
executive
has to sell some shares but trevor
milton sold like 70 million dollars in
shares
before they went public or right as they
were going public and he tried to
explain it
on the podcast and it made no sense
that's a big number 70 million if he
sold 7 million you'd think
okay you sold 7 million he's going to
buy a house
you pay your taxes you got four million
left depending on what state you live in
five million
you can buy a house for that you know
for a ceo to buy a four million dollar
house
you know they're not buying a 60 million
dollar jet or a 30 million dollar jet in
three houses
so that was a major red flag
today many small business owners are
busier
than ever and because they're focused on
managing and growing their businesses
they can't spend the time they need you
on recruiting and that's why linkedin
jobs has made
it easier to find and hire the best
candidates for free
we have had such a great experience
finding
two more producers for this week in
startups researchers to sort through
all the deal flow i get and it has been
amazing it's a great place for you to
look for a job
and it's even better place for you to
post a job
so many talented people are sitting
there
waiting to hear about your career
options for them
and we use targeted screening questions
to get our roles in front of the most
qualified candidates
with the experience skills and
motivation we need then we use simple
tools to filter and prioritize the top
candidates
for interviews and best of all
linkedin's network now has over 740
million professionals all over the world
linkedin jobs is going to help you find
the right person for your role
they're so confident that you're going
to love linkedin jobs
they're letting you do that first job
posting free every week
nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin they're
waiting to hear about their next career
adventure
and you just have to go to
linkedin.comtwist and post that job
listing for free
so that you can make their dreams come
true